So here's a way to define is_palindrome. So we're taking
a single string as an output, I will call it s,
and we're first going to test the base case. So the
base case was to see if the string is empty, we
should return true right away. So we can do that
with an if. We are going to check if s is equal
to the empty string, and if it is, we return true,
that's our base case. For the else, we have the recursive
of case so now we need to do the test of the first and the last characters to
see if they match. And we can do that
using the string indexing operators, as 0 gets us
the first character, s negative 1 gets us the
last character. If they match, then we need to
check the rest of the string. If they didn't
match and let's finish the didn't match case first.
So if they didn't match then we know it is
a palindrome, because we found a place where the first and
the last character did not match, so it should return
false right away. If they did match, well then we have
the harder problem. We need to do the recursive call
to check all the other letters in the strings still form
a palindrome. So this was our starting string. It had
all these characters in it. We checked that this one matches
this one, so now what we need to do is take the rest of the string and check
if this is a palindrome. So that'll be a
recursive call, so we're going to return the result, of calling
is_palindrome. But instead of passing in s, what we
want to do is pass in the string starting from
position 1 of s, so removing the first character,
and ending at position negative 1, removing the last character.
And remember with our indexing, the last value here is
not included. So by having the last index as negative
1, that removes the final letter of the string. So
the first thing to test is the base case. So
we'll pass in the empty string. And the empty string
is a palindrome, so it should give us the result
true, which it does. Let's try the single letter string,
a, that's also a palindrome. It's the same backwards and forwards.
And so we also get the value true, if we try say string ab, which is not a
palindrome. We get false. As a longer test, if we
try a level, we should get true. Which we do. And, let's try
one of the most famous palindromes, amanaplanacanalpanama.
And we should get True which we do.
[BLANK_AUDIO]